حان الوقت لعقد اجتماع من اليسار إلى اليمين في
[موسيقى]
على أصوات المسيرة القادمة التي
تخلصوا من موكب النصر في 24 يونيو 1945
وزير الدفاع الروسي
الاتحادات
أبطال الجيش الروسي الجنرال سيرجي شويغو
يتجه نحو وسط الميدان الأحمر حتى
اعتماد تقرير الجاهزية للاستعراض
القائد العام لقيادة العرض
الجنرال أوليغ في الجيش
سيليوكس
[موسيقى]
نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي
الاتحادات
قوات حامية موسكو للعرض
أنت رحلت
الذكرى 75 للنصر العظيم
حرب وطنية
قائد العرض العام
جيوش الخنافس
[موسيقى]
يبدأ انعطاف الحسابات الاحتفالية للأولاد
تم إرسالك إلى الجيش سيرجي شويغو
تحية الجيش
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في السنوات الأخيرة ، القوات البرية
وصلت إلى مستوى جديد نوعيا
تنميتها موثوقة
الضامن
الأمن العسكري
موظفي الدولة من الأرض
القوات مستعدة دائمًا لتصبح دفاعًا عن الوطن الأم و
والمصالح الوطنية
[موسيقى]